Network file systems has evolved over time, but the idea is still the same. You
have clients that are distributed all over
the local area network and you have file
servers sitting on the local area network
and these file servers are central, so far
as each client is concerned. Of course,
the system administrator may partition these servers and
say that there is one server designated
for a certain class of users. For instance,
if you take a university setting, you
might have one server serving all the faculty's
needs, and maybe another server serving all the student needs, but so far as a
single client is concerned, it is still a
centralized view, access to a central server over
a local area network. Now, since the disk
being electromagnetic is slow, the server will cache the
files that it retrieves from the disk in
memory, so that it can serve the clients better
by serving it out of the file cache that is in memory rather than going to the
disk all the time. So this is a typical
structure of a network file system. A centralized server,
which is the model used in NFS,
is a serious source of bottleneck for scalability.
A single server has to field the client requests coming from the group of users
that it is serving and manage all the data and metadata for all the files that
are housed on this particular server. And the data and the metadata of files
are persistent data structures, and therefore, the file
server has to access these data structures over
the IO bus, which is available for talking
to the disc sub-system. So, with a centralized
server like this, there is limited bandwidth that's
available for the server to get the data
and the metadata in and out of the disc. And the file system cache is also
limited, because it is confined to the memory space that's available in a given
server. So, instead of this centralized view of the file system,
can we implement the file system in a distributed manner? What does that mean?